okay in the last panel the panelists
started talking about innovation and and
I think this particular panel session
will go deeper into the subject of China
being part of the global innovation
network if you look at the evolution of
China it used to be for the last twenty
thirty years the major major production
and supplied site of many many global
value chains and China has evolved from
being the factory of the world and China
of course is still the factory of the
world into a major market and then now
as a potentially major source of
innovation when we talk about innovation
of course I think the last panel has
anchored more on the VCS and also the
startup perspective of innovation but
innovation can also occur from the
fundamental materials used in making
products in the manufacturing process in
manufacturing is also a potential place
where innovation can occur to the
products to the new channels and also
the last panelists also as mentioned
Jenny talked about the business model
innovation
it also can happen besides startup
companies it could also be from existing
large enterprises even government sector
as well as the service sector all can
played a role in innovation so today I'm
delighted to have two panelists one is
Sydney Liu who is the chairman and CEO
of Foxconn interconnect technologies
Foxconn being part of the whole
high-precision group and so that's a
major major electronic manufacturing
surface company and Sydney himself has
out of that world of using innovation to
drive
values and also sitting next to me is
Michael bucks Michael marks is the
founding partner of Riverwood capital
but he also was a former chairman and
CEO of Flextronics and he grew the
company from 150 million dollars to 15
billion before he stepped down so both
of them have tremendous experience in
looking at both from starting germane
innovation seed to also building
enterprises that also have innovation as
a part of the the kind of the DNA of the
company so maybe what I'll start is to
ask Sydney and Michael to share with us
their perspective of how innovation can
happen in China as well as the rest of
the global network so would we see me
would you like to start
okay I would like to mention three
points to frame my remarks innovation
especially on supply chain management
first of all looking at manufacturing
sectors I mean you're you're looking I
just heard a lot of great stories about
IT industry about margins in
manufacturing the margins it's much
lower so any innovation is important for
instance everybody knows that from the
cost perspective $1 say in cost
management for a five percent margin
business equals 20 percent $20 you
earned from the cells so innovations in
supply chains extremely critical now the
meaning of a innovations that Professor
Li just said it's not very limiting you
look at materials you look at processes
you look at business model so they're
all over the place now you look at
innovation incent of supply chain
they're manufacturing now you ever think
about what happens when we start
business for instance in China you're
looking at the ultra frugal
manufacturing with highly efficient of
chain management at a call and this is
really demonstrated by the query China
it's the most competitive nation in the
world for highly cost sensitive
industries by OEM like ODM and like the
basic electronic components why they're
there in China it was China it's so
efficient and you look at supply chain
as a whole
what is that strategically important you
look at all the different brands that we
know about
for instance logistic companies DHL
FedEx and UPS globally of course the
excellence in supply chain management
then you let look at retailers like
Walmart they spin so many different
innovation investment into their supply
chain and you look at complex topics
against the reason why their head of
everybody else's is because they have an
innovative supply chain systems that
supply fresh products into a net worth
of retail outlets and particularly you
look at people like us the manufacturers
how can we take the business of in-house
manufacturing and become their arms of
manufacturing is because we have
innovative supply chain models thank you
Michael
okay well one thing everybody should
understand is we're talking more about
hardware now as opposed to you know
software business models it was it was
interesting to hear the this last panel
and the you know the questions that in
the end you know when when is China
gonna be you know more than half of
whatever the question was you know in in
innovate innovation happening in China
and that way understates the value was
taking place in China today it when
you're looking at the hardware side so
here's how I think about innovation
innovation takes place in the end we're
talking about hardware but it takes
place in a bunch of different places so
there's an R&D lab and we tend to think
about innovation of coming coming out of
an R&D lab that's actually a pretty
small part of where innovation takes
place so you have been you have Rd then
you have engineer and we're lots of that
where lots of innovation takes place
when you get an idea it comes out of Rd
you send it into the engineering group
the engineering group goes and works
with suppliers and figures out what
kinds of materials and how to make
things cheaper and that's maybe the
biggest chunk of innovation and then you
have the factory floor which is an
incredible place where where where
innovation takes place because that's
where you're finding out how to make
things cheaper and better what works
what doesn't work you're constantly
innovating on the factory floor then you
have the supply base which is another
incredible place where where innovation
takes place which is suppliers coming up
with ideas of how to of substituting
materials or how to do things cheaper or
how to do them in a different way and
then you have logistics which Sydney
just talked about which is an enormous
ly valuable part of the of innovation
and if you look at lots of companies I
mean it's one thing to talk about
inventing Facebook but it's another
thing to talk about innovations like
Whole Foods you know which is a very
successful company United States
basically just just a grocery store but
but but coming up with a different way
to present it you know go after a
different demographic if you will that's
hugely innovative has created a huge
amount of value without
coming up with some rocket science
innovation GoPro you may know is a
company that that that has created a you
know a cameras no magic to it cameras
are out there but they packaged it up in
a slightly different way and they
marketed it you know to a different
group of users and it's been a hugely
innovative and hugely successful company
so so many of these places where
innovation takes place is actually weird
where China has excelled you know when I
was running Flextronics in the early
days way everybody did products the
United States to have the manufacture in
China was you would you would develop
the product United States and you would
you know start manufacturing and you
would do prototyping and you do all this
stuff to sort of get it all worked out
and then send it over to China to do the
work and that turns out to be just a
horrible idea and it's a horrible idea
because it ignores all that innovation
that takes place you know what's already
happening in China incredibly
efficiently and incredibly effectively
where you get all these inputs from from
the suppliers and from the engineering
people and from the factory floor people
and all that kind of stuff so so ten
years ago 15 years ago most people got
the idea that why don't we take
advantage that's a very valuable thing
but but then let's not ignore all these
other places where innovation takes
place which if you look at it China has
been absolutely breathtakingly fabulous
on this topic and so now that's that's
moved much more to taking advantage of
all those kinds of things that take
place in China and so it's it's like
it's it's terrible to listen to people
talk about there's just not that much
innovation in China because that that's
really wrong and if I can just make one
other example one of our portfolio
companies is in the LED lamp business
which everybody knows now is you know
this is taking over from from
incandescent compact fluorescents and
it's a us-based company with us-based
R&D and US based manufacturing and one
of the things we did when we got
involved as we went over to to China
specifically where it turns out you know
ninety percent of all the of all
lamps in the world are made in a 25-mile
area and the amount of innovation taking
place is there which is maybe not some
of the the fanciest stuff and all of
that but the amount of innovation that's
driving costs out and creating product
proliferation and all this kind of stuff
is absolutely breathtaking and we've now
transitioned not only the manufacturing
but maybe 80% of the Rd into this into
this place where there's all this really
cool stuff going on and the costs have
dropped by 30 or 40 percent and even
more importantly we're getting to market
faster we're getting you know higher
quality more differentiated products and
so this is not a us only thing so I'll
stop there well given that Sydney and
Michael both have this deep experience
with the two largest EMS companies in
the world Foxconn and electronics so I
have to ask this question is that any
growth a few years ago wrote an article
in Fortune magazine which I think have
stirred a lot of discussions and his
point is that innovation will require
manufacturing and design being closely
together and interacting with each other
and and I also have read that like
Apple's highly innovative products
arguably innovative products of iPhone
has to depend a lot on Foxconn not just
in manufacturing but also in part of the
innovation and Cisco's successful
product Viking router depend on Foxconn
when Microsoft introduced Xbox is highly
dependent on electronics so it's no
longer purely Microsoft or or Apple or
Cisco individually successfully
innovating and so behind every
successful innovative product sometimes
maybe there is behind it a very powerful
whole innovator so I wonder if Sidney
and Michael can share what do you think
is that is that true is it truly that
innovation
wires multiple players working together
in some cooperative fashion and that
would accelerate innovation and China
plays a role because of the
manufacturing deep expertise well you do
because if you look at the speed of
innovations in terms of pushing our new
product into the market right and I mean
traditionally the approach let's say ten
years ago is you have engineers during
their closet during their lab spaces
they trim up something they mock it up
they tested it this thing is great but
they computer using computer-aided
technique and do some optimization they
think it's great then they ship it out
but the problem is for the last two
decades many fetching basis has shifted
from United States to Asia particularly
China so a lot of what we call DFM
design for manufacturability the
expertise is actually shifted so when
you're looking at product development
especially advanced productive elements
it's great to dream up something in the
lab but it's very different when you try
to put it into mass production I'm not
talking about making it up making it up
you can make one or two great-looking
models but how do you make sure you
consistently have them out in the volume
of millions and make sure they're
consistent and they have their quality
and also to make it to the target cost
those are very important attributes and
also skills that unless you have a very
close collaborative effort from all the
stakeholders the material suppliers the
process engineers also the design
engineers the people who making them and
people who designing them people who
marketing them working closing together
as a team you're not gonna get his
thesis that is really just that simple
you know I'd say the same thing you know
when you're a hammer everything looks
like a nail and I'm a supply chain guy
and so I think that if you don't take
advantage of what the supply chain
offers you just won't won't be as
innovative a company so I start there so
you know what the bias is but you take a
look at the the you know the iPhone is a
perfect example I mean what are what are
some of the innovations in there one is
you know Gorilla Glass which came from
Corning I mean that's a supplier base
driven innovation that was a huge impact
on that or a titanium case which comes
from the ability of the of the supply
chain guys to come up with a way to
create titanium and created into into
and to make it in that kind of product
or you can go back even earlier to you
remember the Motorola RAZR which was a
very very innovative cell phone was
maybe the most successful cell phone
product ever until until the most recent
round which was there the innovation was
making an incredibly thin and having a
touch touch sensitive keyboard and those
innovations actually came from like our
companies and I will say we don't get
paid as much for doing this let me look
at Apple's margins versus supply chain
margins but but truly innovative
companies again talking about hardware
take advantage of this stuff take
advantage of the logistics management
and the suppliers and the materials guys
and all that kind of stuff and
incorporate that into the into the the
products that they're developing and if
they don't do that iPhone doesn't exist
I mean you know so our companies weren't
the ones who did the user interface but
our companies were the ones that did
lots of other innovations that went in
there that you all accept is coming from
Apple or Motorola or whoever's behind
every successful man there is a woman
and behind every successful product
there is a supply chain anyway so I am
going to ask one last question but I
hope that you will start thinking about
questions and come out to raise it with
our panelists to see their perspective
right so this question is that in the
last panel I think there was some
discussion about the fact that some
products or some software in this case
mostly because the previous vendor was
focusing more on the software side we're
not successful in maybe maybe as wildly
successful in the US but it's important
into China and it became hugely
successful so this is a
temptation i Quarry adaptation product
adaptation that is the innovation came
from maybe Europe maybe us but then
adapted into China and the classic
example in China is all these sanjaya
cell phones right
all these Sanjaya cell phones the pirate
cell phone imitation cell phones or
others imitation products do you
consider them innovations
well innovations can be very broad
if the innovations to me has got to have
two attributes that are most important
first it has to be new or unique has
never been done before and second it has
to serve a purpose it means it has to be
better if it's not better then it's
you're just making something new new is
not innovating right it has to be better
better than what you're trying to
replace or you're trying to improve upon
so it has to be better and it's been
unique new and unique and it has to be
better in some of the sons I some of the
future we see yes I see some some of
that but a lot of that is well new for
the sake of being new for instance I
mean few years ago I go to sunshine as
it is cellphone with six B speakers it's
like one of those hot rod you can put it
on the street you know I mean you're you
listen to the to the cell phone and
usually I mean blow your eardrum out so
I mean it's it's new but it's not
innovative works innovative and not very
useful yeah look I'd go back and use the
example of you know GoPro I mean
everybody has cameras but there is a
particularly users who you know who
needed a camera that you know wouldn't
break when you dropped it and you could
mount on different things and all that
so the the innovation there was adapting
you know something that's perfectly well
known to a group of users who wanted to
use that in a slightly different way and
that's created a hugely innovative and
valuable company that's no different
from taking a cell phone
you know the cyanide cell phones and and
and adapting something that exists to a
population that wants to use it in a
slightly different way
and hugely valuable companies have
created about this and you know this
copy thing where everybody goes like Oh
China is not very innovative because
they copy things or we do a lot of
investment my firm also in South America
Latin America you know Brazil and other
places like this and you know people
start out by copying and it's it's sort
of it's not the nice way to say to say
something really because it acts like
this isn't important and all these
people are doing is they're adapting
maybe it started in America everybody
sees how successful it is that's great
but taking that and adapting it to the
to the local population to how they
think differently how they work
differently
how they interact differently that is a
perfectly valuable approach to
innovation as opposed to start with
something brand new good yes I am going
to ask my audience to see if you have
any interesting perspective yourself to
share and and also questions for our
panelists on a subject of global
innovation network yes please hi I have
a sourcing and product development
supply chain backgrounds and so I've
done a lot of work on the ground in
Chinese factories and while I I see a
lot of innovation that you mentioned I
also see a lot of gaps and so I wanted
to ask you I wanted kind of talk about
some of the things that you mentioned
around this close collaboration that's
needed from so many different parts of
the supply chain in order to actually be
innovative and get these products to
market what kinds of needs do these
organizations have what are what are the
gaps that you see within these within
the supply chain and then you know like
what tools are they using to collaborate
there's a really big difference between
taking the 250 years of
industrialization in the US and
squeezing it into 30 years in China but
there's some key differences between
that time and and now which one big ones
the Internet so I'd love to see or hear
from you what you think the big
opportunities are there
sorry I don't get the other questions
but I try to address it's the best I
could supply chain innovations
if you look at it basically what the
supply chains means supply chains means
is you have a product from raw material
all the way out to customers you make
them you take them to customers and if
you look at the supply chains today
there's so many opportunity and chances
to innovate and one of the examples I
gave as a home high corporate it's the
vertical integration model but very
going to Gretchen does is a lot of the
expertise it's already in-house all
right and also the collocations so you
don't push the goods you don't ship it
around all over the place it's mostly
it's me it's the most efficient way to
operate and on top of that you look at
the last mile that means the products to
the end customers and we've been doing a
little bit of that for instance weaving
actually shipping our finished goods
directly to our customers and we already
doing that in China and what does that
do is that fulfill the last mile so you
go from raw material minimal amounts of
trafficking and then you have it all
done pretty much in a central located
place and then you ship it out to end
customers right so you fulfill from end
to end and that way really you really
reduce this order WIP
in the pipelines and that to me it's
very important but in order to do so
there's a lot of technology innovations
you needed to get it there right I mean
the mass amounts of coronations among
all the different layers from materials
have finished goods all the way to goods
you know it's it's it's really my
boggling for instance on display along I
mean if you look at LED LCD display how
many layers are
semiconductor process you have to go
through on top of that the layers of the
glasses the people made and then you
have to reduce the sinners of reduce the
thickness of it to the certain level and
then you actually bind it together if
you look at some of the TV screens I
mean just making the screen itself you
probably ship the materials half around
Asia already so how do you have the
innovations and also have visions to
bring others related suppliers closer to
your raw materials and also closer to
your end market and optimize on that
that is all by itself the biggest
challenge innovating and we're doing
some of them yeah I agree that I mean
distance is one gap for sure and that's
why you hear a lot of talk about you
know we bring manufacturing back to
United States and all that stuff I so
that's for sure really big challenge and
it's getting somewhat easier the other
two challenges that I see particularly
in China since we're talking about China
is flexibility and communication I mean
these are places where there's more work
to be done so in all manufacturing to go
back to the history of manufacturing all
manufacturing facilities want long
production runs and and and be able to
plan everything easily and we've got
we've become a very different world
about that where everybody wants to
customize and do something right away
and that is not necessarily the strength
of Chinese manufacturing so that's one
in communications also obviously another
another issue you the questioner asked
the you know asked about the impact of
the internet the internet the good news
about the Internet is it's making both
of these things easier I mean it allows
you to communicate you know very rapidly
you know in real time you can draw
things and see them you can you you have
much better you have much better
communication tools and you also have
the the ability the tools if you use
internet right to deal with the
flexibility part where you can have
orders coming in every day or every
minute instead of being bunched up and
sent over once a week or once a month
you know you you have much more
visibility if using the internet - what
the supply chain is and what
suppliers are doing and what your
customers are doing in this so on but
those are definitely two areas where
there are some gaps between sort of the
the best in the world and sometimes what
takes place in China thank you with a
question there and then switch my name
is Samir Ayane and I have a question
about intellectual property in China so
there were more patents filed in China
last year compared to the US and for
example Han high has tens of thousands
of patents so going forward with all
this innovation happening in China how
do you see the patent landscape laying
out do you see companies starting to
litigate more patterns do you see
companies using patents more
domestically to restrict competitors or
is it more for the international market
so you are these bands being filed for
international markets only or is it
going to have a domestic application to
in your opinion rephrase that you're
asking about intellectual properties
right yes patents okay yeah and your
question is the parents in your shining
lots and lots of patents what are you
going to do with them okay great
I understood intellectual property is
very important pattern is its it has its
value and unfortunately a lot of the
companies outside of the United States
does not recognize that value if you
look around the world and look at the
patterns and usually the people who
collected patterns you see most of that
money flow actually is coming to United
States versus anywhere else
Asia alone you look at Korea you look at
China you look at you know coming like
us we're we're actually applying a lot
of patterns we're coming off to the
world so you look at top 20 patterns
holders in the world a lot enough
foreign companies but unfortunately
between say United States
and some of the companies in Japan if
you look at had an income and there is a
huge disparity and that is because of
the education and myself companies in
Asia
maybe TSM seems probably only one of the
exception they mostly apply pattern they
do it the wrong way they do it as a
defensive major they do is they are
gonna keep my competition out they do it
they say I'm gonna apply pattern so when
people sue me I don't have a protection
shield that is wrong that is not how you
treat pattern pattern should be an asset
you look at how valuable Motorola is I
mean there's a company making phones
they're probably not very successful in
the end but their pattern works a lot of
values that's why Google acquired them
and you'll get patterns is that's reason
why United States we got this pattern
troll company that go out there and buy
the pattern the people for God and
actually their basic patterns so you
have to educate your people on pattern
application this pattern is an asset
okay it's not a protective measures I
mean it does have values but you have to
my death and then you have to have a
system to actually release that value
out okay so Michael Lee they designed
this Foursquare I was just up there a
little bit earlier I'm really interested
in your views on 3d printing and in
particular do you see this sort of a
challenge to manufacturing supply to
traditional to apply change do you see
this as something that augments that
what are your thoughts 3d printing
first of all 3d printing is it's not
gonna challenge the traditional
manufacturing it's the scale is too
small okay but 3d printing has its place
we actually use 3d printing I was the
first one introduced 3d printing into
Hong hi pet in 1992 so 3d printing being
around for a long time and it's one of
those technologies that have improved
through the years it's great in terms of
doing prototyping doing mock-up symbols
doing your conceptualization so it's
great it has its place but in terms of
mass productions no it's not there yet
it's too expensive and also it's too
slow yeah but I also need to add to that
because I have a slightly different
point of view of course I completely
agree with with what Cindy said but I do
think it has the potential to be
disruptive because it's only now that
people are starting to figure out how to
really work with 3d printing that
there's a that that there's the software
and the tooling for and all that kind of
stuff and you know it's probably never
gonna going to have an impact on really
true high-volume manufacturing but what
I was just talking about before is that
this you know mass customization where
everything wants to be a little bit
different I think there's a hugely
disruptive opportunity but it's likely
to be decades not years I mean this
isn't something that's gonna happen
tomorrow another question in the back
yeah hi my name is Jeff Hagen I'm with a
jewel we are an innovative manufacturing
company so my question and my
perspective are not unbiased and you'll
probably hear that my questions around
funding of innovation and we've been
talking about software and if you walk
around Silicon Valley that's all anyone
talks about these days and historically
I think if you look at the funding
cycles there has been a cycle and it's
been hard we're chasing software chasing
hardware and the funding has gone along
with that but in the 30 years that I've
been operating in Silicon Valley and I
just repatriated from China
I've never seen an environment that is
so negative with regard to hardware and
manufacturing innovation pure scientific
innovation and the funding of it and
it's really at a nadir that I've never
seen and so it's a kind of two
question the first one first part of it
is have we fundamentally moved away
particularly in Silicon Valley from ever
funding hardware and manufacturing
innovation again number one and number
two who is funding it I don't it's it's
it's hard to find anyone willing to do
it I said to me you probably laugh at
this but Silicon Valley has lots of
vision and no money and China has lots
of money and no vision because I'm an
investor today right and I and we are
for sure
funding hardware and nobody is you said
this exactly right this is just
unbelievable to me I mean I just tell
you a quick little story about this so
like semiconductors I mean you you know
Silicon Valley was you know silligan for
semiconductors and like nobody wants to
go near a semiconductor company today
and we're investing in and we've made
four commitments in the last 30 days and
here's what's really interesting about
this you know Silicon Valley was created
all the venture firms here were started
by by semiconductor guys you know Don
Valentine and Irwin Federer and these
guys they were all retired and and all
the young I'm sure those venture guys
and I don't know who the audience is
here really but everybody just hates
hardware I mean the most successful
company in our portfolio and really one
of the most successful hardware
companies in a long long time is GoPro
and and we made this investment and we
got turned down by some of the best to
join us in this one because people just
hate this kind of stuff the
semiconductor business said everybody
hates today has turned into exactly the
kind of business that that Silicon
Valley investing venture investing was
based on which is it's a software
business it's you know you have TSMC and
USMC at UMC who are doing all the you
know all the hard we don't build
factories anymore you take a bunch of
hotshot engineer so I'm sure there's
lots of them in the crowd here who you
know work in a 40 by 40 space doing
software and they go to TSM seem to get
a sample and then they sell their
companies for like you know 5x a year
later and nobody's doing this but we are
Riverwood capital remember that
so can we have lunch together yes Alan
weighing from LinkedIn question as costs
and actually is everything as prices and
of land and factories and labor rise in
China what is the future for two types
of products one are obviously the ones
that are more lower skill labor
intensive and of course products on the
other side that are priced more higher
skill or require more technological
investments what are you what is your
view on what the rising costs how that
affects those two types of products well
first of all let's look at this
phenomenon and challenges in China China
has firm one-child policy and it's
increasing the impact on both labor
demographics and the nature of the
workforce okay first foremost is the
effect of the total labor pour from the
inverted demographics pyramid so
workforce has reduced worrying to the
second generation under this policy you
know fewer people are going into the
workplace and also by nature of this the
second generation coming in I mean
they're coming from a relatively
prosperity better living standards and
also the facts that they grow up in
Internet space so there are very less
patients in terms of manufacturing jobs
and thoroughly because a lot of them are
actually the only child so the center
universe surrounds around them right so
in terms of manufacturing where you
actually place a premium on teamwork
collaborative work it's gonna be very
difficult so there's a lot of challenges
here and the cost of wages for the last
ten years have been increased 15 to 20
percent every year we all know that the
important thing is well how do you get
your productive
jain's how do you go out automation
processes and some of the really
labor-intensive vibration we see
actually go to Southeast Asia in some
other lower wages places but that itself
does not solve the equation because what
happened is when you go across the
border for instance to Vietnam to
mini-mart and Southeast Asia's you
bringing yourself other questions there
are challenges for instance I mean when
you go to the places that are not as
connected as China so a lot of the
material still need to be ship around
and then you have the taxation costs and
those are the challenges you have to
overcome so it's not a simple question
as to okay I have a labor-intensive
operations
now China widgets has been up for the
last ten years now I'm gonna find a
place with much lower wages and actually
has a plenty for supplies of Labor's and
I just stripped my operations over there
well that is only solve the equations of
wage but that doesn't solve the cost of
the other stuff associated with it I'll
throw out something that's not probably
gonna get talked about any other place
today but it's something that people are
not talking about and it's gonna have
more of an impact than than the rising
cost of labor in China and that's the
cost of energy you know one of the great
innovations taking place in the world
today is shale gas and what's happening
is the cost of energy is dropping like a
stone in the United States compared to
the rest of the world and that actually
has a gigantic impact not on every
industry but on a lot of industries and
that's gonna be a big driver which is
not China going up in cost because it's
sort of stable there but in fact
dropping fast in the United States and
that actually is going to shift a little
bit of the balance here I think we would
have time for two more questions but
maybe what I would do is to ask each of
you to raise the question and then we
add the panelists
to pick and choose the answer yes my
name is Gregory maker and you guys
recently feel that a question about
hardware funding and my question is in
the past we've had large companies like
Apple and Sony Samsung not necessarily
Samsung but Apple and Sony that become
large customers of contract
manufacturers recently because funding
has dried up contract manufacturers have
developed their own vehicles to fund
nurture and grow these companies
internally so Flextronics Lee's recently
launched lab IX are we gonna see the
next Apple and GoPro coming from the
likes of photon or Flextronics and are
we moving into a future where these
companies are gonna be grown internally
my question I'm Bob March a vicar's from
specialized bicycles and my question is
how do you see China being impacted by a
lot of the free trade agreements that
are happening right now whether it's TPP
or TAFTA or some of those other big
trade agreements that are really
designed to I'll say take the focus off
of China as a manufacturer and supplier
okay oh that is a good question
China joins WTO in 2001 and the Beijing
government began negotiating a network
of bilateral trade agreements focusing
on Southeast Asia many of the Kim the
effects actually came into place
actually now 2010 what we're seeing now
is Asia's wealth developed economies are
actually investing a lot more money on
capitals into the less developed ones
and what this means is we're seeing
supply chain reaching across borders
now intervene
Laos Cambodia mini Mars and elsewhere
okay
and it is driving some of that way but
like I said earlier when you do that
you're also facing with a lot of
challenges critical factors including
the basic input cost logistic cost
energy cost management cost and local
transactions and Taxation cost free
trade agreement does put some after
manufacturing footprints into Southeast
Asia no doubt about it it's happening
but how big an impact of that we started
seeing some of it since 2010 okay it's
not at the level where we see a paradigm
shift but there's something you say love
it
so I'll take the first one it's a it's a
good question and he actually goes to
the to the purpose of a lot of what's
going on today anyway about innovation
I don't think so an answer your question
the question is you know are you gonna
see you know great companies spawned out
of the contract manufacturers I don't
think you can and the reason is the
really great entrepreneurs engineers
designers they want to work for these
kind of companies that I don't mean that
in a pejorative sense I mean I ran one
you know he ran one I mean so we did
this for a living but these companies
are trying to add more value right to
try to get their margins up so you do
more on the R&D side or you you know you
fund things that you think and turn into
can turn into customers but we always
had that try me when I thought
Flextronics we had you know 15,000
engineers around the world or 25,000
whatever the number was but but great
entrepreneurs the people who can go
create the apples or Samsung's of the
world whatever that is
these are not the companies that they
want to work in they don't have the
margins that are the infrastructure they
don't have the panache and so I don't I
don't think that ever happens but all of
you are still part of the innovation
network right yes
yeah yeah I think on that great note let
me thank my two panelists for is sharing
with us the perspective